passion refers to a strong feeling of
enthusiasm or excitement either for
something or about doing something
passions are often something you would
love to do constantly
finding your passion is often
interlinked with happiness and
fulfillment on a more deeper level
but you might be asking yourself how do
I find my passion
so here are some steps you can take to
help you discover your passions
reflect on your interests and hobbies
think about the activities that you
enjoy doing in your free time
what are you naturally drawn to
what do you find yourself spending hours
doing without getting bored
these interests and hobbies can often be
a starting point for discovering your
passions
pay attention to what excites you
pay attention to the moments when you
feel most energized excited and happy
think about what was happening in those
moments and what you did that made you
feel this way
reflect on your values and goals
consider what is important to you in
life
what values do you hold
what do you want to accomplish
your passions can often align with your
values and goals
get feedback from others
ask friends family and colleagues for
their honest opinions of your skills and
strengths
they may be able to provide valuable
insight into where your passions lie
keep an open mind
sometimes finding your passion may not
happen as expected it may come in
different form or as a combination of
things so it's important to keep an open
mind and be willing to adapt
seek guidance and mentorship
talk to people who are doing what you
think you are passionate about
they can provide valuable guidance and
help you discover your passion
experiment and explore
don't be afraid to experiment and
explore different Passions
it may take some time and effort to find
something that truly resonates with you
but it's important to be patient and
persistent in your search
remember that discovering your passion
is a journey and it may take time and
patience but by following these steps
you can start to gain a better
understanding of what truly drives and
fulfills you
thank you for watching And subscribe for
more